looking at the history of humanity there
are a lot of people who could be
considered
significant and to have impacted the
world
to various degrees but i think very few
people can stack up to the figure
of jesus of nazareth at least in
hindsight and
assuming that he existed he must be
considered one of the most
famous people who have ever lived and
want to have had an enormous
impact on the world and its culture and
history
at least symbolically he's a central
figure to some of the largest
and most influential religions in the
world
including of course christianity islam
and the baha'i
faith but jesus can also be quite an
elusive
figure and different people often tend
to have very different
ideas and views about who he was
if he was and what he stood for it is a
greatly debated topic among historians
today as well and of course there's
disagreements here too
but it is of course a very interesting
subject
and will be the main theme for our
discussion in this video
who was jesus of nazareth
[Applause]
[Music]
i like jesus according to the way he is
described in the gospels of the new
testament
he seems like a pretty swell dude but
that's precisely the problem isn't it
how accurate
are the gospels and the new testament in
describing the actual life or
teachings of jesus it of course serves
as the
basis for mainstream christianity's
perception and understanding of who
jesus was but this is by no means the
only perspective
the figure of jesus is one that despite
his great importance to so many people
there is a huge disagreement about and
many different peoples
have very different ideas and opinions
about who this man actually was and what
he meant
to mainstream christianity jesus is the
incarnation of god's word
the son in the holy trinity and thus
identical with god himself
to muslims baha'is and certain minority
groups of christians
he is a great albeit human prophet who
brought revelation from god
similar to other prophets like muhammad
or moses
to some hindus jesus is sometimes seen
as an avatar for the god vishnu
to others jesus is a myth he never
actually existed but was the creation of
the early christian writers entirely
in new age circles too he is often seen
as a great enlightened being who taught
about christ's
consciousness there is even theories
today that
jesus was in fact a psychedelic mushroom
or rather that the figure of jesus is a
kind of metaphor
that represents a mushroom that provided
enlightenment
but out of this myriad of different
perspectives how can we know which one
is the most accurate
well to put it simply we can't
but it's also a lot more complex than
that of course historians and scholars
have for a long time been trying to
figure out
who the historical person of jesus
actually was
but as i've said there is also great
disagreement and debate among scholars
and academics on this topic too
but what i'm going to do with this video
is through scholarly academic historical
sources
explore what we can actually know about
one of the most influential figures in
history and we'll do so by answering two
main questions
first we will ask did jesus actually
exist and how can we know if he actually
existed
and then secondly if he existed then who
was he
what did he teach and how did he view
himself okay so before we start any
discussion on this subject
we should discuss methodology and how
scholars and historians view the
criterium of historical sources
what scholars look for when retelling
history
is to find sources or material that are
as reliable
as possible and there are usually
different levels of reliability
the best kind of evidence for a
historical person like this is of course
direct material evidence from the person
him or herself
things like a house objects that the
person owned or
literally remains like books directly
written by the person
if none of this exists we have to rely
on secondary sources such as
stories about the person told by others
eyewitness accounts and
like the more material the better of
course and the closer to the actual
event
in time the better contemporary sources
that come directly from the period of a
person's life
so from a person's lifetime are of
course the most reliable
but if this is not possible then we want
the sources to be as close in time as
possible
this means that for example when it
comes to the life of jesus
purely from an academic perspective the
bible is a more reliable source than the
quran
since the latter appeared 600 years
after jesus lived
and the new testament only a few decades
ideally
the sources we employ should also be
unbiased and
neutral but of course in most cases this
is pretty much a lost
cause in some respects this means that
if we have mentions of a person like
jesus
from people who are not christians this
is often considered more reliable
than christian sources themselves for
obvious reasons
and with all of this in mind what do we
have in terms of evidence or sources for
the life of jesus
well sadly not much at all actually in
terms of material evidence we have
basically nothing there is
no archaeological remains or findings
that can prove
jesus's existence there have been some
claims in the last few years that
they may have found jesus's house the
house where he grew up
in nazareth but this is nowhere close to
certainty so we can't really rely on
that as a
as a source as such in terms of
contemporary written
material for written sources from
jesus's own lifetime
there is nothing here either now this
isn't that surprising since of course
most people in first century palestine
couldn't read or
write and jesus during his life would
probably not have been
famous enough for him to be mentioned in
any kind of official
documents either but this lack of
evidence is indeed problematic
and there are many who argue today that
jesus
never actually existed as a historical
person that he was a
later construct by christian writers and
this is a somewhat serious idea or
theory that can't be overlooked
completely
since there is at least some merit to
this idea
however the fact is that the majority of
scholars
historians who work on this subject
hold the opinion that jesus was indeed a
real historical person who lived in 1st
century palestine
this is because the sources that we do
have are convincing enough
that scholars think that this is the
most likely option
now as i said there are no contemporary
sources from the time of or the life of
jesus
but some sources start to appear not too
long afterwards and the earliest
sources for the life of jesus is
actually the
some of the books of the new testament
itself of course based on the criterium
i talked about earlier
the new testament accounts would
definitely fall under the category of
biased but this doesn't mean that they
should be discarded completely
the new testament does give us some very
significant historical information
and much of it is deemed trustworthy the
earliest written books of the new
testament
are usually considered to be the letters
of paul likely written sometime around
the year
50 a.d this is only around 20 years
after the commonly believed death of
jesus
which is pretty close in time paul of
course never met
jesus personally so he can't be
considered an eyewitness as such
but his letters show that very shortly
after his death
jesus's death there was a community of
jesus followers that were widespread
across the roman empire
they also suggest that there was a
community of leaders in jerusalem at the
time
including apostles like james and peter
who indeed did
meet jesus but while the letters of paul
suggest to us that there was some kind
of community established at this time
they don't really talk much about the
life of jesus to any large degree at all
this is instead left to the four gospels
when it comes to the gospels there is
universal agreement among scholars
that they were not written by the
disciples of jesus directly
but by later christian writers a widely
accepted theory is that the earliest
gospel the gospel of
mark was written sometime around the
year 70.
the gospels of matthew and luke being
written slightly later around
80 to 85 and the last gospel of john
sometime in the 90s a.d these gospels
can often have
seemingly different and contradictory
views and perspective on who jesus was
and on certain details of his life which
we will return to later
but they all describe him as a person
who lived and walked the lands of
palestine
and even though they aren't contemporary
sources they were written about
40 to 60 years after jesus's life which
is
indeed relatively close in time many do
accept the books of the new testament as
evidence enough for the existence and
life of jesus
but others are not as convinced luckily
however we also have sources from
outside
of the bible who are written also just a
few
a couple a couple of decades after the
life of jesus and
they are of course they meet the
criterium
of being an outside source so not a
christian source
and thus also not as subject to bias
at least not insiders bias of course you
could argue that there is
there could be a bias in the opposite
direction but nonetheless we have
sources from outside the bible which is
also very significant
the earliest and most significant of
these is by the jewish historian
josephus
he is often considered one of the most
significant jewish figures of his time
and a hugely important source for what
we know about first century palestine
and in his writings there are sections
that are certainly very important for
our current discussion
in his book antiquities written around
the year 93 a.d
josephus talks about an event that
supposedly took place in the year
62 a.d when a religious leader called
ananis misused his power
and had a number of people executed the
text reads quote
so he assembled the sanhedrin of judges
and brought before them james
the brother of jesus who was called
christ
and some others and when he had formed
an accusation against them as breakers
of the law
he delivered them to be stoned not only
does this of course mention jesus
and the fact that his followers called
him the messiah or christ
but also talks about james jesus's
brother
who was an early leader of the community
this is a significant historical
document and one of the best evidence
that we have for jesus but josephus also
provides another perhaps even more
striking section
which has become known as the
testimonium flavianum
this is a much longer reference which
goes as follows quote
at this time there appeared jesus a wise
man if indeed one should call him a man
for he was a doer of startling deeds a
teacher of people who received the truth
with pleasure
and he gained a following both among
many jews and among many of greek origin
he was the messiah and when pilate
because of an accusation made by the
leading men among us
condemned him to the cross those who had
loved him previously
did not cease to do so for he appeared
to them on the third day
living again just as the divine prophets
had spoken of these
and countless other wondrous things
about him and up until this very day the
tribe of christians
named after him has not died out
now most consider this quote to have
been tampered with in some way and
for good reason josephus being a devout
jew who never converted to christianity
would obviously not have referred to
jesus unequivocally as
the messiah or that he rose on the third
day
so it is widely accepted that the
original quote was probably edited by
later christians
who added some theological flavor to it
but still if we look past those obvious
theological statements
the original message of josephus seems
to give us some significant basic
information
namely that there was a wise man called
jesus who gained a significant following
among the jews
and who was believed to do remarkable
things he was executed by crucifixion by
pontius pilate
but continued to have devoted followers
even after his death
these statements by josephus are some of
the most significant
non-christian sources that we have but
there are more of them as well
another often quoted source is the roman
historian tacitus
in his annals of imperial rome written
in 115 a.d
he talks about the great fire in rome
that broke out in the year 64 and
under the emperor nero and while talking
about this event he writes quotes
nero falsely accused those whom the
populace called
christians the author of this name
christ
was put to death by the pro-curator
pontius pilate
while tiberius was emperor but the
dangerous superstition
though suppressed for the moment broke
out again not only in judea
the origin of this evil but even in the
city of
rome these and a few other sources from
around this time as well as the books of
the new testament and the non-canonical
gospels
is basically what we have to go on when
it comes to
reconstructing the life of jesus and
the early community that formed around
him and based on this as i mentioned
the consensus among scholars is that
jesus was indeed a real person
and that there are some things with
reservations
that we can know about him and this
brings us of course to that second
question that we are to address in this
video
who then was jesus again
there is huge disagreements on this
question
both from people within different
religious traditions that conceive of
jesus in different ways
but also among modern modern academics
and scholars but there are a few things
that
seems most likely to be true about him
and his life
and which most scholars agree on jesus
of nazareth was a jewish man who was
born
sometime around the year zero some
scholars have suggested 4 bc
and grew up and lived in 1st century
palestine
in adulthood he seemed to have gathered
a group of followers among his fellow
jews through his preachings
it seems that one of the main features
of this preaching
was that the kingdom of god was soon to
arrive
sometime around the year 30 he had
aroused the suspicion of the authorities
and he and his followers seems to have
caused some kind of ruckus in jerusalem
perhaps because of this or that the
authorities generally saw him as a
problem the roman governor pontius
pilate had him executed through
crucifixion
it also seems pretty certain that very
shortly after his death
his followers were convinced that he had
risen from the dead
this basic outline is a somewhat safe
way
of thinking about jesus based on the
historical sources that we have
this is what we can know with at least
some level of certainty
and anything outside of this framework
immediately enters the realm of
speculation
and theories and boy are there many of
those
we have already talked about some of the
many ideas about who jesus
was since so little is known about him
as a historical person
he is almost infinitely malleable and
different people often like to fit him
into their own narratives jesus was a
socialist he was a feminist
jesus was a capitalist he was a radical
revolutionary he was a pacifist
all kinds of different interpretations
exist out there
of course from the historical
perspective of what we do know
some of these portrayals may be said to
be more accurate than
others but at the end of day it is a
subject that is so shrouded in mystery
that it's hard to say anything
definitively if we again look at the
earliest sources which are after all the
christian sources themselves in the
different gospels
they also seem to showcase a variety of
perspectives
the mainstream churches of christianity
which developed gradually over the
centuries
accept the idea that jesus was the
messiah promised in the old testament
he was the son of god or the incarnation
of god's word that took human flesh and
died on the cross to bring salvation to
all human beings
the question of the nature of jesus
divinity was a hot topic
even 300 years after he lived so one
would expect
similar discussions in this early period
scholars who hold ideas
similar to that of bart ehrman argue
that the idea that jesus was divine or
a divine being evolved gradually in the
years after his death
influenced by greek culture and religion
not everyone accepts this idea of the
gradual
development of jesus's divine identity
in the canonical gospels of course
but it certainly seems that the
different
gospels sometimes tell different
versions of the events
and when we start to look outside of the
canonical
gospels things get even more complicated
the literature found at nag hamadi in
1945
includes what is often referred to as
gnostic gospels
scholars today usually reject this term
as the literature seems to represent
various different movements only a few
of which can rightly be attributed to
the so-called gnostics but regardless
what it does give us is a deeper look
into some of the different forms of
christianity or jesus movements
that did not become part of the later
orthodoxy
when looking at early christianity we
should not see it as
one orthodox strain that continues from
jesus and the disciples onwards and that
there are various sects that diverge
from this orthodox
stem instead early christianity is
really an explosion
of just a multitude of different
interpretations
and ideas and and perspectives on jesus
and the bible
and and all kinds of different questions
and it is only a few centuries later
that a so-called orthodoxy would be
established
and in the nag hamadi text the writings
of some of these
what would become non-orthodox forms of
christianity
survive and they often have very
different ideas and perspectives on who
jesus was in places like the gospel of
thomas
themes like the crucifixion are not
present at all
that is not to say that they denied the
crucifixion but they did not share the
ideas of the proto-orthodox thinkers
that it is the salvific nature of the
crucifixion that is central
to christian belief or the salvation of
human beings
instead the gospel of thomas and other
early texts emphasize
that it is gnosis knowledge of god and
the divine realm
that is the only way to reach salvation
jesus is a divine teacher still the son
of god in most places
that teaches us how to achieve gnosis
namely through
knowledge of ourselves and our true
spiritual reality
the nature of jesus and his function was
a topic that continued to be debated for
centuries
with the exception of the ebionites a
jewish christian group who considered
jesus to be a human prophet
and messiah everyone basically agreed
that jesus was divine in some way the
question was
how the orthodox position eventually
came to be that jesus is both
fully human and fully divine the
so-called
gnostics however seem to downplay his
human nature
and make him a purely spiritual being
now we're not going to get into
christian theology at this time but the
takeaway here
should be that even in the very earliest
forms of jesus movements and
christianity
there was huge diversity and
disagreements about who
jesus was and so that of course doesn't
help us very much at all it really makes
things even more difficult for us when
we try to
recreate an accurate picture of who he
was
of course jesus is a significant figure
in the religion of islam as well
and by extension also to the baha'i
faith
but in islam and the baha'i faith jesus
is
only considered to be a human prophet
much like
moses or or abraham in this long line of
prophets that
according to islam ends with the prophet
muhammad
jesus or isa as he is referred to as in
the quran
is sometimes called the spirit of god
but he is never considered to be divine
or the son of god so his divinity
or his sonship to god is denied in the
quranic narrative but as we've said the
quran appears
600 years after the life of jesus
and as historians and in historical
research
we of course don't operate from the
perspective that the quran is the actual
word of god
and so this means that the quran can't
be used as a source for the life of
jesus
any more than the bible can we are thus
left with somewhat of a mystery
even the earliest sources in the gospels
both canonical and non-canonical
give us different accounts it is thus
left for scholars to engage in educated
speculation
some probably most place him very firmly
within the jewish tradition and his
message as being a reflection of that
others may see him as more of a kind of
philosopher akin to the writers of the
wisdom literature of the old testament
etc
for me i prefer the former option i
think if there is anything we can know
for
certain it is that jesus was a jewish
man who
operated within a jewish context in
first century palestine
with all that that entails all of the
things jesus talks about in the gospels
like
the son of man the messiah the kingdom
of god
it is all present within the jewish
religion
when we look deeper we see that jesus
very much fits into his time and place
for example a movement known as jewish
apocalypticism
was very prominent at the time which
thought that an apocalyptic event was
soon approaching where the dead would be
raised and everyone would be judged by
god
either being sent to eternal damnation
or to a kind of paradise
and all of this shows up in jesus and
later christianity
he is a man of his time in a lot of
different ways
as such many scholars today see jesus
and consider jesus to have viewed
himself
as an apocalyptic prophet and messiah
who warned his fellow jews that this
apocalyptic event
and thus the kingdom of god was coming
soon
the fact that jesus was operating within
the framework of the jewish religion
seems inescapable and this also is
corroborated by the bible itself
in any case jesus's identity as a jew
and the historical context in which he
grew up and lived
is the starting point from which all
sound theories about this
should be based but is one that many
still
fail to take into consideration jesus is
a symbol that means a lot of different
things to different people
and that's the way that figures like him
function at the end of the day we are
left with
very little certainty however scholars
will agree that jesus was most likely a
real person who lived in 1st century
palestine
most of them will also agree on the
basic points mentioned earlier
he was jewish he gathered a group of
followers he made the authorities uneasy
and he was executed by crucifixion
by pontius pilate somewhere around the
year 30 a.d
and his followers believed that he rose
from the dead anyway i hope this video
gave you a broader
picture and perspective on the
historicity of the
figure of jesus of nazareth now this
video is a collaboration
with two other fantastic youtube
channels
with who is a channel that talks about
primarily
islamic history he has beautiful
visuals and is a great storyteller
and you should definitely check out his
channel it's one of the best historical
channels
on youtube especially when it comes to
islamic history he
will in his video be talking about the
historicity
of the prophet muhammad so don't miss
out on that
secondly i'm also collaborating here
with the channel called useful
charts which again is just a fantastic
historical channel that has a
very nuanced and interesting perspective
to share
on various aspects of history
and also topics like religion and in
this case
useful charts will be talking about the
historicity of the prophet
moses so all of that will of course be
incredibly interesting so if you enjoy
this video
you should definitely go check out their
companion videos
and don't forget also to subscribe to
their channels again i hope you enjoyed
this video and if you want to support
this channel you can as i've said
become a patron or choose to make a
one-time
donation i'll leave all of the links to
that in the description
or you can simply of course like the
video or subscribe to the channel
and leave a comment and i'll see you
next time
[Music]
you